darf ich einal kurz übersetzen also sie
wollen sie verstehe ich den Gedanken
richtig sie sagen es wir werden es nie
schaffen sozusagen ein solches
Überangebot an Wohnungen zu erstellen
genau das Überangebot müsste so massiv
sein dass so viele Wohnungen leer
stünden dass das echtten ernsthaften
Druck auf die Preise ausüben würde der
einzige Fall der mir bekannt ist wo das
funktioniert hat in Anführungsstrichen
ist in Ostdeutschland in den 90er Jahren
das ist die Bevölkerung zurückgegangen
gleichzeitig hat man ich glaube über
eine Millionen Wohnung häufig auf der
grünen Wiese neu gebaut das Ergebnis
waren eine Million stehende Wohnung und
Bundesprogramm bundländerprogramm stad
um Bost mit dem für über eine Milliarden
Euro leerrstehende Wohnung 360.000
leerstehende Wohnung wieder abgerissen
werden mussten das ist aus ökologischen
infrastrukturellen finanziellen und
sozialen Gründen nicht das wo wir hin
[Musik]
können